the end of an era has arrived no time to
die will be Daniel Craig's final for a
as British superspy James Bond his fifth
Bond film in 14 years making him the
longest-serving man to play the role
let's break down the trailer for this
bonds final bow bond and dr. Madeline
swans drive off into the sunset at the
end of Spectre was apparently the only
retirement announcement mi6 was ever
going to get bond took off to Jamaica
to live an idyllic existence on the
water he's been there with Swan for five
years with his colleagues believing he's
dead from the end of 2015 Spectre to the
beginning of 2020s no time to die the
real-life and fictional timelines
basically align here life has gone on
without bond exactly as he wanted it's
given the shown of lynches know me the
opportunity to replace him as a double O
agent and acquire a significant amount
of experience no me also appears to take
on a more militaristic tactical style
but clandestine operations compared to
bonds suave tuxedos look dr. Swan is
hiding something
why betrayal we all have our secrets the
no time to die trailer suggests a bun
the Madeleine will break up following
that betrayal considering her father was
mr. white the assassinated Spectre a lie
and that she was very aware of spectres
existence she no doubt has an insidious
history she's worked to burry if she
knew about her father's criminal ties
was she possibly more of a party to it
than she originally led on
it's also possible dr. Swan has some
connection to Sutphin the villain played
by Rami Malek because she's been sent
the same mask he wears could bum be
trying to avoid we experiencing the
heartbreak Vesper Lynd put him through
at the end of Casino Royale at the end
of Spectre Bond relinquishes spectre
leader Ernst Stavro Blofeld played by
Christoph Waltz to mi6 head Emma for
arrest now in custody
and under what appears to be solitary
confinement Blofeld is a highly
important prisoner it's the most
valuable
so this country has but every good
supervillain knows how to turn the
screws while in captivity until the
moment they can once more act
independently and that cunning is what
draws us back to character archetypes
like his again and again Hannibal Lecter
became a movie icon from a prison cell
after all
Emma spun to not lose control in blue
felt presence given all the horrors
Blofeld has orchestrated and inflicted
upon bonds life bond says he would never
do that but then turns a corner to find
dr. Swann with a folder clearly
suggesting a psychological profile they
haven't seen each other in what seems
like a while and now meteor preparing to
speak with Blofeld Blofeld knows dr.
Swann's secret too and weaponizing it
against bond as surely a masterstroke in
a grand plan it's been a while since
you've seen CIA agent Felix Leiter in
the James Bond franchise the character
has been a staple of Bond franchise
films since the first film dr. no but
the version played by Jeffrey Wright
hasn't appeared since 2008 Quantum of
Solace only rating a mention inspector
in no time to die Leiter seeks out his
now retired friend to take an
off-the-books assignment I need a favor
brother you're the only one I trust for
this but how does he know bond isn't
dead
we need answers Felix long time James
Bond franchise producer Barbara broccoli
describes rami malek Sutphin as the one
that really gets end up on skin a nasty
piece of work he appears in the no time
to die trailer as limping and scarred
he even holds his gonna build Lee his
villainous connections aren't clarified
in the trailer but it's difficult to
believe he doesn't somehow fight back to
Spector and Blofeld in summers yet
unknown way and some fans are theorized
he's really an updated doctor know who
was a member of Spectre the word know
isn't the title of the movie after all
either way Sutphin clearly sees
parallels between himself and bond even
saying he could be speaking to his own
reflection
when monologuing to the famous agents
but he sees one big obvious difference
New York is done with her body
- survive long after I'm gone it seems
like the steaks in no time to die with
involve Bonzo mortality against the
world threatening plots that have become
standard for the franchise with no time
to die a Craig is officially finished
playing bond and nobody has been
officially announced to replace him
audience says we'll be saying goodbye to
a specific iteration of bonds that has
transformed a franchise we've known for
50 years
Craig's bond has gone from being a
fresh-faced rookie in Casino Royale and
to basically a hermit to actively hates
his job
because as killed his humanity he's an
orphan who was never known familial
connections except for with one person
Judi Dench's M who died a terrible death
right in front of him vengeance and mass
have been key themes through all the
Craig Bond films and like most of his
predecessors versions of the character
Craig's James Bond has often been
completely wrong and has time and again
being portrayed as desperate he's no
immortal superhero he's human and he
asked the help because he knows exactly
where his strengths begin and end as
much as it annoys him to emitter and he
is always always tired
that doesn't cheapen his bond it makes
him more real than owed time to die
trailer sets the stakes around bond
himself his life his friends his love
the threatened destruction isn't
strictly political or social it's
personal
which is really the perfect bookends for
Craig's bond maybe James Bond that does
need to die and in doing so represent
the humanity that's been so central to
the character since Casino Royale fans
can find out everything when no time to
die opens in theaters April 2nd 2020 in
the UK and April 8 2020 in the u.s.
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]